[Music]
we've all heard the tale of the young
star the Phenom someone so
unquestionably gifted that they were
destined for greatness from birth but
what about the journeyman the grinders
the people who live and breathe on
airplanes switch teams yearly are
overlooked tossed aside written off
their husbands constantly on the brink
of watching everything they've ever
worked for slipped through their fingers
but somehow they persevered they never
let go no matter the cost because they
have a dream you have a coach that
became a player probably best coach
all-time five-time major winner with og
and he comes back and does this as a
player this is the story of one of those
grinders of a guy who saw his career
come and go only to reanimate it and
become a more
this is the story of
[Music]
he's an armchair
[Applause]
his lifetime
Sebastiao said Deb's started his
professional dota 2 career way back in
2011 just as the first ever
international had vaulted the game into
the limelight but back then he wasn't
known as Seb he was [ __ ] mad and he
here with me
I [ __ ] mad from Team Alliance and I'm
here with [ __ ] mad
actually sitting here with [ __ ] mad
he originally signed on with a roster
called team Shakira that year they
finished fourth place at Dreamhack
winner which led the Western wolves to
pick up the roster but roster shuffles
were common in that era of dota and said
was no stranger to them even early on in
his career Seb was known as an
analytical player he had a commanding
voice and wasn't afraid to use it
to get his opinions across he was
confident the kind of guy who would tell
you how he felt no matter what yeah it
was the beginning of I know it wasn't
easy like it wasn't what it is today
unfortunately if you if you lose you had
no money to pay for your rent you the
other day like I remember playing
Dreamhack sand we had no money to pay
for the hotel were sleeping on the floor
the very night so you think what I was
about losing again you know like you you
it was a do or die it was truly the
winner die kind of thing he joined a
team called mortal teamwork in 2012
ahead of ti2 and qualified for the main
event alongside his new squad they need
something fuzzy is being ripped the
throne is on 250 live finally the kill
is done MTW taken they will travel to
Seattle for the international headed
into ti2 many actually looked to MTW as
contenders for the aegis of champions
but despite all the hype headed into the
event they tripped out of the gates
finishing with a record of 3 and 11
jobs are rabid monthly with a double
Mowgli winner triple and it's the ELSA
GJ am TW are the first team to be
eliminated from the International 2012
there's the pressure and the way we work
treating each others as the teammates I
think was pretty immature back then you
know I try to like give every every year
like every day I look like a reason or
like a team or why we failed that one
was Team Dynamics and that spelled the
end of yet another stint on a team for
sub this was kind of the story of his
early career
he'd flip-flop between teams never
living up to his potential on the
biggest stage by the end of that era
he really was a bit of a nobody in the
professional dota world between 2011 and
2015 he played on 13 different
professional teams and after that
disastrous performance at ti2 he was
very much thrust out of the games upper
echelon the community began to know him
as just an arrogant kid with some talent
that never really measured up to the
rest of the game's best I was like it's
been it's been a while now it's already
already been like five years or
something of competing and I felt like
my ideas they were good enough to win
this ti is even and yet so I'm sitting
there not even making it to the main
event ever if I can I'm not even making
it to the tournament so I'm like you
want to be confident you want to believe
you want to chase your dream but you
don't want to be delusional he wasn't a
phenom he wasn't the game's next star
and things were only going to get worse
in 2015 subs career revved its engines a
little when he signed with a former Ti
winner in Alliance but the team had a
mediocre showing and delete up to ti5
and failed to qualify for the biggest
event of the year you know it's almost
heartbreaking why couldn't they have
played his role in Game one as they did
in game one throughout the rest of all
fires have GG well played
and with that alliance slips down in the
last place along with burden United and
they see their hopes for the
International 20
fifteen come crashing to an inn and
despite some improved results from
alliance later in the year Seb couldn't
keep up and after ESL one Frankfurt he
was without a home once more it was hard
to get that team anywhere until soon
like I just reported it felt like it
felt like we were just begging ourselves
against like our heads against the wall
only this time he wasn't about to find a
new one any time soon
despite the struggles he faced in his
pro career Seb was a student of the game
he was one of those guys that was just
obsessed with dota whether he was
winning or losing he fixated on draft
strats pocket picks micro and macro
strategy and in general he always
thought he knew best so when things went
south with alliance he dipped his toes
into analysis and casting where he
became a bigger community figure than he
ever was as a player but have you ever
like thought about settling down as a
cast or analyst I think like in a near
future there is actually room for that I
actually enjoyed it a lot I think it's
lots of fun and I'm really interested in
the strategy so it fits if it's that's
for sure but above everything else I'm a
competitor ie I want to play that game
to the highest level try to win games so
no I never crossed my mind for any
second I can do that while I'm on a
break if I have time I I'd be glad to do
it I enjoy it a lot but it's saying
before everything dota fans actually
began to celebrate the high level of
analysis he could bring to the desk he
boasted expertise that's hard to come by
in such a deep and complicated game so
sad thoughts I think I borrow has to
play the same way they didn't game on
you do the fact that they were
aggressive robbed them had like they
actually call it the off guard many
times and they crushed them in many
openings but it's also what lost them
the game so they need to find the right
balance it's gonna be tough but they can
do it it was during this era that his
reputation as a prominent dota 2 mind
grew immensely but his highly
opinionated personality also got him
into trouble he famously faced rabid
community backlash after calling RTZ
overrated but even though his pro career
was largely a failure that was just the
way sub was
the kind of guy who said what he thought
and meant it no matter who he might
offend yeah they said well what are your
final thoughts on that when that game
for eg I mean I kinda expected he'd owe
me a complexity and no offense to
complexity but I think it is the
strongest team there's probably a lot to
do with my temper with our am I mean I'm
a very like I'm a person like I like
challenges at that point in 2016
said was adrift he was a smart guy but
his professional career had never really
measured up to his game sense and the
volume of his voice but at the end of
that year sab got a fresh start
Oh G brought him in as an analyst during
the run at the Shanghai major and then
immediately hired him as a head coach
after the event I felt very unsatisfied
with my career path I felt like I I
could do like much more I could have
done much more in DotA in general I
never really met its my expectations of
what I was capable of but I never really
gave up on my dreams of like really
testing what I was capable of even back
then
Oh G were known as the type of team to
do things their own way
so despite SEDs waning prominence the
union made a weird kind of sense he was
a big brain who wasn't afraid to break
the mold and that was exactly what
oh gee wanted the way he spoke about the
game you could tell it wasn't just
passion it was brains and this is kind
of what we saw and to say that it was a
match made in heaven would be an
understatement it was very clear that
this was the best opportunity I've
gotten to that day to prove myself like
once and for all there was not gonna be
any doubts so that was the perfect
scenario so I just went for it the team
was built around fly and no tail two of
the scenes closest and most beloved
players they rounded it out with
Prodigal miracle moon meander and crit
and with Sabbath the helm the W's
continued to roll in
oh they can't withstand the punishment
major champions second time the first
ever team to repeat not only did they
take home the trophy in Manila but the
team credited a lot of their success to
their new coach a huge shout out to our
coach said this would have never
happened without him
Sebastian thank you so much for this it
was it was a dream come true like
everything just you know the stars they
aligned like all these experiences that
I've had in the past they made sense
they started being useful and og rode
their victory in Manila to yet another
win at ESL one Frankfurt
fashion headed into ti6 they were among
the favourites to hoist the ages but
like everything in subs career it wasn't
going to be that simple
the team was absolutely massacred at TI
losing to heavy underdogs TNC in the
lower bracket your whole life was about
that tournament when it ends I don't
think you quite accepted brain just
doesn't process the fact that it's all
good but OG were an enigma they bounce
back from their failure at TI with
another major title in Boston and picked
up 2017 s first major in Kiev they were
the winningest team in major history
they had unrivaled chemistry and some of
the most talented players in the world
with each major title each triumph said
reputation as a coach grew when the
highest level of Dora is played when
every little detail is thought through
it's something that is beautiful in the
sense that I've never found this in
anything else in my life give major we
found our strengths and it's a bust and
really brought us together as a team
just like one of the players and he
deserves the moment to celebrate with us
but when it came time for the
International the game's biggest stage
they just couldn't measure up
[Music]
Don't Tell snacks they keep on going
no bye that's a three the end is nigh GG
LGD slay the feast they move on that
loss left an everlasting undeniable tear
in the fabric of OG dota the heart and
soul of their organization fly and no
tail wouldn't be queuing in two games
together in 2018 fly took s4 and left og
after ti7 it was a huge shock like we
for sure didn't see coming
not much was said they max three
sentences were spoken in that room then
they left you spent eight years together
and no it's over oh gee were in shambles
in the end
oh geez majors weren't enough dota
simply isn't about majors if you can't
perform a TI it's time to go back to the
drawing board and that's what they had
to do in the lead-up to the
International eight so forming a team
three months before TI and having a shot
at winning TI no not happening
Oh G had lost their captain they looked
like a shell of their former selves and
the dota world more or less wrote them
off just months before TI they still had
two holes in their roster and there were
no top players that they could sign on a
moment's notice so they found a ringer
so as soon as we got his box I
definitely thought of Gaia but the
majority was like who the hell is Dobson
sab brought in Thompson a finished pop
star with almost no competitive
experience to play mid on I came back
this time to play position one and no
tail had taken over the brunt of the
leadership role and fly's absence oh gee
were being patched together
but one piece was still missing the real
question is why not Sebastian as a
player instead of a coach what I wanted
is the team to win
I wanted us to play at the highest level
of thought whether it's me playing or me
coaching whatever it is this is what
this is the number one part this is what
makes me happy they were beaten they
were broken but they were going to give
it a shot after all when the TI lights
turn on
anything can happen with the odds
stacked against them oh gee rose to the
challenge they didn't start the event
off too strong but they proved during
the groups that they could still hang we
just got to work and try to fix
everything we could think of that had to
be fixed and ended up working that's the
hand of God living for the moment the
two-person shackle this cookies turn
around but the illusion to take it down
often with the decimal a damaged Hall
it's dirty and the tip to food at the
same time another tornado comes out and
that's enough to finish mound each step
gets the bharatas well that's it GG is
the call from iceberg wind strike they
don't get their win against og and they
will be forced into a tiebreaker they
played a different style of dota under
sub that year in many ways their in-game
performance was a direct reflection of
having a coach in the booth they weren't
afraid to level the opposition try that
weird pocket paper cheese strat they
were a coach's team and along with some
heroic performances from everyone on the
roster that style landed them a spot in
the upper bracket where they promptly
dispatched vgj storm - OH
in this game I lift up there with the
you'll suffer like as well
[ __ ]
all of a sudden this team filled with
outcasts who've been written off before
the tournament even started were within
striking distance of a TI final but
standing in their way was a familiar
face fly and Evil Geniuses if they
wanted to make the Cinderella story come
true
if Seb wanted to seize the career he'd
always dreamed of
they'd have to dispatch the person who'd
been there when it all started
Oh je vais is DG will Ram doubt date I'm
so excited all of those I particularly
want to see the lesson I think it's safe
to say or safe to say that this
[Applause]
Tashtego stock is back up the high
ground plus but no tow comes out the
grid and Hopson keeping out of it all
hang on
they'll take him into this global gonna
keep the try card they get upside down
[Applause]
oh he's gonna finish
[Applause]
[Applause]
so here we have this gang of brothers
they to overcome all the odds conquered
maybe their greatest nemesis and found
themselves in the upper bracket finals
of Ti a single match away from the final
what was next
well now they had to make history a
Chinese team had always one ti during
even-numbered years and og or facing off
against that region's juggernaut and the
world's top-ranked team PSG LGD who
looks poised to repeat the pattern
century waka has planted and is still
out of range of an observer and century
they'll see nerds all jump in right on
top of them he doesn't have that
reincarnation back up against a nerds
house down banana he turns on the
damaged BKB with a black head jerks that
helped mountains on mr. standing his
ground the cold a great local damage
anymore it's all up the set he looks for
his target
they [ __ ] three dr. Wilson is done but
he ends up
[Applause]
Jarett
oh gee
the control and learn
[Applause]
they reached the
the major never
was shattered into pieces
somehow OG were on their way to the
finals of the International 8th we're
gonna play the Jag and finals I'll be a
player in the Jag grand finals that's
just that sounded unreal I think they're
just gonna be fearless when it came time
for the grand finals
they had a rematch on their hands Oh vs.
PSG LGD the grand finals of Ti 8 we've
been waiting for this moment all day and
now a best of five series between these
two teams to determine who is the best
at dota 2 this year
give me a tree in game main stage man
Tokyo's got his monkey like in more than
one way this match was all about Seb
sure no tail was a top player with a lot
to prove
Thompson was surging on to the scene and
Anna had redefined position one
throughout the tournament but if AG were
going to win ti they need to outsmart
LGD they need to get in their heads he's
gonna try to jump I'm gonna cancel it
oh boy dead [ __ ] [ __ ] zip Negro
soldiers vo out from this year but the
beecharmer presents coming down they've
got the changed stuff around is still
alive for now they get the double kill
the court approves keep it
the winters Gus honeyBun heat I chose
the jealousy judges on fire
oh gee took the first game but after LGD
fired back two games in a row they found
themselves with their backs against the
wall back against the wall we knew we
were gonna get tested we are getting
tested yes this is a rough situation to
be in of course but we're gonna overcome
it together and then came game for the
biggest game in OG history and notably
the greatest game of Seb's life
yes yes just see my guys I'm [ __ ] this
is my game boys
much like games two and three they found
themselves behind but this time an
overlooked French coach with a mind for
the game was not willing to lay down and
die
Chubby's still pretty beefy but easy
beefy enough I don't think so the shots
are out dropping it in the spin
retirement yards he said with the death
of OT who was Samus again the
doppelganger army October Thompson
Thompson being saved by Derek shags him
the tenor of attorney Edward M another
call
that fully load you need that's under
step for two minutes they catch up to
total newbies so Donna Anna Chinese do
it here is it all
[Applause]
you did not
[Applause]
on the back of Seb and his timely acts
Peck it was time for game 5 and with
that said call ringing in the back of
the minds of millions around the world
oh gee did the impossible this is the
game of our life's month enjoy game 5
grand final T is like everything is
gonna come together next game everything
and it's gonna be beautiful user himself
what the Flav
g-53
tours of the surrounding in defense of
this hill
ing as only action I left alive
suppose the minute they were [ __ ]
no economic level the ancient is exposed
as OG the news
gets themselves another narrow to the
ancient
[Applause]
champions
no I misread it it's like it felt like
we couldn't lose for some reason it's
not like it was impossible to us it's
like some games like I don't know we
were like two sides behind him 20 I
don't even know like how bad it would
nothing was going for us yet it felt
like this game was fine like it was it
was I don't know how to put it maybe
we're just doing a dick I don't know it
felt like we were not gonna lose and we
didn't from a shattered team to TI
champions in just months perhaps the
greatest story in the history of DOTA
and at the heart of it all was said a
guy that caught everyone off guard even
his own team we all knew he had the
smarts but in 2018 he played better than
he ever had he played like a TI champion
Sebastian left retired to become a coach
it was like well you know what I want to
be back I want to be a player after all
these years I here is they did it they
lived the dota dream they were legends
after tea I ate they underwent some
unforeseen hiccups involving sub during
the year when despite his newly minted
heroic status in the world of dota he
reverted back to the sometimes toxic
attitude he made a name for himself with
bro I went T IU ba player means I talk
you listen
understand thank you parts of the
community were up in arms when Seb made
hateful comments towards Russians in a
public game and there were cries for
Valve to confront Seb about the issue
even as a dota legend said that was
still the same old soloqueue trash
talker
welcome to the International
20:18 was nothing short of amazing the
story almost writes itself but that
doesn't change the fact that this was
largely a tape together team and even
with the added chemistry a win like that
can bring OG weren't the favorite
heading into ti9 far from it but when
they got back on that stage that special
feeling returned once again they
finished first in their group playing
the kind of dota they become known for
just a year earlier it was time for this
team to show everyone it wasn't a fluke
it wasn't just fate they were the best
and that became clear all too quickly
much like the year before not even fly
could stand in their way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to the winner's bracket final repeating
the history of CIA
AJ neither could LGD break on the
terrace me to leave destruction going
out on a feed business disrupted his
loosens got to see windows it's gonna go
from top scampi kami agri-food bulkheads
are on him rusty tacks on hoping about
her splitter
Oh God
goodnight buddy stock done enough
the physical damage will overrun the
throne at PSG Ltd and the three versus
five can no longer
Oh
breakdown
[Music]
a decade
they will have the opportunity to defend
their drug
if you come at the king's you best not
miss a Sebastian I mean honestly I
dedicate this tournament to him no but
really Thank You Sebastian and of course
everyone else she's so [ __ ] lucky if
you think so [ __ ] good
oh gee were back in the grand finals of
the International nobody had ever won
back-to-back TI's no single player had
even one - but as they stared down Team
Liquid across the stage that is about to
change
shackleton rather looked amateur turns
back in a way talk to
we'll still out of mana because of
instance he's ready to try to promote
potentially attorney that one's finish
is a kite Thompson he's on top of her
back into the car
FICA jawbone
when surrounded and there all day
oh gee
and they're even taunting they toss them
to the dragon
they're just giving their guiding found
in tea
and get him to chase Tamara close but oh
my god I can't believe this
I got me Wilma Sega this game for
[Applause]
and in what a fashion these last three
games didn't even seem co-sleeper they
had something going for themselves but
then they hit the brick wall
oh jeez another bet best team in the
world
no question about so far ahead of
anybody else
the blaze this game for living oh gee
the best evil old-timer with this that
second gee I win and not just the second
thing I went for the second back-to-back
they do it two years in a row there is
no question that we're witnessing the
best team of all time
[Applause]
there are no words that can do what Oh G
has accomplished over the past two years
justice they proved everybody wrong
about what it meant to be champions in
this game and at the heart of it all was
one grinder a dota feed said a player
who is never meant to be the greatest
never fade it to be a household name
someone who never stopped working and
never gave up on the dream a symbol of
the obsessed of the incredible journey
that is dota where the thing you want
more than anything to be truly great can
slip right through your hands only to
reappear amidst chaos to change the game
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]